à la maison dans votre voiture ou en
soirée vous avez forcément déjà dansé
sur les sons endiablé de Gilbert
Montagné
les sunlights des tropiques the full on
va s'aimer font partie de ses plus
grands succès
[Musique]
ce tube des années 80 va d'ailleurs
s'écouler à plus de 700 000 exemplaires
et marqués à jamais ce lien si
particulier entre Gilbert et les
Français et c'est un plaisir vraiment
Johnny Hallyday Tina Arena ou encore
Véronique Sanson il va jouer avec les
plus grands
[Musique]
en 2012 Gilbert Montagné interprétera
son propre rôle dans le film stars 80
allons mettre qui revient sur la
naissance de cette tournée phénomène
regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en avril dernier où il sera dévoilé en
demi-finale sous le costume de l'arbre
et c'est Gilbert Montagné mais
aujourd'hui c'est pour nous parler de
son premier roman pour enfant que
Gilbert Montagné nous fait l'honneur
d'être sur le plateau de TPMP people
sur une étoile
dans un terrain j'espère que tailler ton
histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais calme avant d'arriver
au bout du nez le pour découvrir
la biface il se découvrir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde alors vous êtes là
alors Gilbert quand vous parlez vous
pouvez le poser parce que vous avez des
micro sur les côtés
[Rires]
alors je salue tout le monde Isabelle
[Applaudissements]
depuis 50 ans
[Rires]
quand j'étais en coulisse alors moi
j'arrive pas à crier comme tout le monde
la intervenants je suis je suis plutôt
cool
mais mais je voulais dire que si par
exemple et pourquoi on t'a jamais pris
par exemple comme jury à The Voice moi
je crois que je suis pas assez aveugle
pour
[Applaudissements]
à quel point les gens vous aiment c'est
facile non c'est là ici tout le monde
les équipes c'est on est tous quand on
vous voit on est heureux j'essaie d'en
rester digne je trouve que c'est une
grande chance sincèrement depuis 50 ans
je fais je fais mon métier public je
m'éclate encore plus qu'avant et j'adore
les gens je la joue pas je la surjoue
pas je publie que dès que je sors chez
moi je suis public ce que je suis sûr
maintenant c'est quand les gens prennent
des photos on n'entend pas les critiques
sincèrement
sincèrement je suis retourné l'autre
jour à l'école où j'étais aux Invalides
ouais ouais tu as vu qu'ils ont mis ça
sur le boulevard des Invalides
que tu sors pas de louper voilà
j'étais en train de penser je me disais
voilà tout petit quand j'étais à l'école
je rêvais d'être sur scène pas
spécialement en avant moi j'aurais très
bien pu être derrière accompagné
quelqu'un ça n'aurait pas dérangé j'ai
pas un problème d'égo mais quand j'y
pense c'est merveilleux de de d'avoir pu
réaliser une partie de mon rêve mais ce
qui est encore plus beau mais vraiment
plus beau c'est de vous avoir vous tous
et toutes
[Applaudissements]
vous savez que vous faites partie de ces
gens quand on vous voit on est on est
plus heureux après on est on est
rechargeable mais je vous promets après
on a l'impression qu'on peut faire
encore des choses j'ai des questions à
vous poser peut-être même intime
j'espère que vous me répondrez parce que
mes questions sont peut-être idiotes non
il y a pas de question idiote on s'est
adorable mais est-ce qu'avant juste
comme ça parce que les gens le demandent
on peut se faire un dessin animé des
tropiques ah oui bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hein
[Applaudissements]
voilà on avait un petit bout et vous
savez que
vous savez que
vous savez que je le reconnais je suis
fan d'une marque on dira pas qui finit
par Med ou c'est un club pour s'amuser
tout ça
tous les soirs et depuis 20 ans que j'y
vais ce sont les choses dont Gilbert
Montagné et les gens sont comme des
choux
c'est vraiment ça ça m'étonne vraiment
parce que j'arrive pas d'habitude je
trouve ça c'est merveille surtout
qu'attend la chanson c'est là ça va être
pile je voulais vraiment la faire et mon
producteur de l'époque en Italie a mis
non je crois pas que c'est une bonne
idée
pour vraiment on était à la fin de
l'album on avait fini l'album et moi je
voulais vraiment la faire et pour une
fois je me suis pas planté parce que on
mangeait pas les cartes je sais jamais
je sais jamais quand ça va fonctionner
ou pas évidemment sinon on serait tous
numéro un tout le temps en 84 c'est
l'album qui cartonne le plus et l'autre
jour j'écoute une émission d'Éric
Jeanjean je salue sur la tête c'était
superbe idée Barbelivien et qui disent
écrit des chansons pour tout le monde
mon plus gros succès c'est les sunny des
tropiques pour
pour vous et il dit je l'ai écrit parce
que c'est pareil je devais la rendre le
lendemain le mardi pour le mercredi bah
oui et Gilbert Montagné qui m'attendait
il me dit j'ai écrit ça sunlight des
tropiques série mais bien il dit à
l'époque il fallait des rimes en Nick
alors tropiques machin et ils disent que
du coup j'espère que géographie on m'en
voudra pas la géographie c'est n'importe
quoi l'équateur à côté de machin il a
dit c'est machin c'est pas grave et vous
saviez quand il vous la donnez cette
chanson c'est bête ma question mais vous
saviez que vous aviez un un vrai tube
parti pour 40 ans ou pas du tout ah non
du tout non moi j'étais content de la
faire parce que c'était mon idée et puis
j'avais imposé donc j'étais content mais
ouais parce que quand tu arrives à
imposer les trucs c'est bien mais non je
savais pas du tout bien sûr pas du tout
non non non non on va pas tous se faire
mais liberté liberté
de musique alors je connais tout le
temps tu vois pardon c'est quand même le
Stevie Wonder français
il a fait il a été dans les shorts
américains tout à fait oui parce que
vous avez cartonné également aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable dans tous les pays vous avez
des cartons pourquoi vous partez aux
États-Unis alors parce que c'était mon
rêve ah oui mon rêve c'était parce que
j'étais un fan de radio quand j'étais
môme et j'écoutais les radios en cours
parce que c'est là où on peut attraper
on pouvait attraper les radios les plus
lointaines et puis moi j'avais une ma
tante était à Philadelphie et pour nous
qui venions d'un milieu très très
modeste c'est con cette expression un
milieu modeste
finalement on était très bien qu'on
n'avait rien on était très bien ouais et
pour nous pour aller en Amérique parce
qu'à l'époque on disait en Amérique bien
sûr en Amérique c'était quelque chose
d'inaccessible bien sûr donc maman a
emprunté un peu d'argent à son travail
là et puis on a pris l'avion et je me
souviens très bien la première chanson
quand je suis en 67 quand je suis arrivé
Isabelle quand je suis arrivé dans
l'avion la première chanson que j'ai
entendu c'était pas si sledge qui
sentait
[Applaudissements]
et alors imagine moi quand je suis
arrivé aux États-Unis j'avais fait mon
portable était un peu naïf mais c'est
pas grave j'avais un petit cassette et
puis je touchais le la terre aux États à
l'aéroport Kennedy pour moi c'était un
grand flash pour moi c'était un parce
que il y avait la musique que j'aimais
bien sûr
il y avait tous ces gens-là et vous avez
inspiré bien maintenant quand on entend
les les dans un poteau on vous dit
arrêtez-vous feu rouge tout ça c'est
grâce à vous j'ai beaucoup travaillé
là-dessus il y a beaucoup travaillé dans
différentes villes pour aider les les
les les les aveugles les distributeurs
de billets le billetterie quand vous
allez retirer de la Belgique comment
vous faites pardon non mais je
comprenais pas je vais tout vous
raconter je comprenais pas pourquoi
d'abord au début les claviers n'étaient
pas identiques c'est-à-dire vous avez
des claviers ou le 1 et l'été en haut
d'autres banques vous êtes en bas
n'importe quoi et donc j'ai ramé pendant
20 ans mais j'ai réussi à convaincre le
monde de la banque pour moi c'était une
fierté que il y a des distributeurs qui
sont
identiques mais il y a une prise en bas
à gauche et vous branchez votre casque
et vous avez la séquence des
informations c'est à dire insérez votre
carte tapez votre code prenez la carte
tout ce que nous on veut rien de plus
que vous mais rien de moi mais vous
est-ce que vous avez la chance forcément
avec votre carrière vous êtes toujours
quelqu'un qui vous accompagne du coup
dans la vie de tous les jours quand vous
marchez et tout ça pour faciliter votre
vie ou parfois vous êtes seul tout
simplement alors bien sûr que je suis
très souvent avec avec mon épouse Nicole
bien sûr et fantastique et puis des fois
ma sécurité rapprochée bon pour les
concerts mais moi j'aime aussi être seul
alors l'autre jour
ça m'a vraiment excité cette affaire je
suis arrivé à Carrefour Market vous
allez au Carrefour Market bah ouais
pourquoi pas bien sûr je voulais faire
parce que tu sais des fois tu as envie
de jouer pleinement ton rôle donc tu dis
à ton épouse écoute bouge pas je vais
fais-moi une liste je vais aller
chercher bon moi j'aime bien et je suis
et malheureusement il y avait que deux
personnes c'est-à-dire avec le monsieur
fantastique à la caisse automatique et
puis le garde de sécurité il m'a dit
écoute j'ai bien on peut pas on est que
deux et ben je veux dire je lui ai dit
ben si on peut parce que moi je veux pas
bouger tant que quelqu'un ne vient pas
m'aider oh là parce que mais c'est une
loi ça s'appelle un nœud RP et un
établissement recevant du public et doit
y avoir quelqu'un qui vient t'aider nous
on veut pas c'est pas le monde qu'on
demande on demande de pouvoir faire nos
courses tranquillement et de payer avant
de partir c'est pas compliqué non c'est
pas compliqué mais vous avez raison et
vous vous battez pour les autres ça ce
qui est très beau et ça ce qui est très
beau
et en position et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs pour finir je vous
remercie la personne et un jeune mec qui
était là un consommateur il m'a dit ben
moi je veux venir avec toi et on a fait
nos courses mais c'est vrai que quelque
part quelque part c'est ça fait de la
peine parce qu'on se dit pourquoi
pourquoi ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait
que soit nos voyants j'ai pas subir ça
on n'a pas à vivre ça bien sûr ou comme
les gens qui sont sur un fauteuil
roulant ça peut arriver n'importe qui
d'entre nous et quand tu as un truc sur
les étagères va le chercher tu peux pas
donc c'est n'importe quoi il faut de
l'intelligence même et je fais de
l'intelligence et quand je vois un
connard qui se qui se gare sur sur les
passages piétons ou pour les fauteuils
roulants ou les voilà et Dieu sait que
j'en fais des conneries moi c'est les
voix des bus pardon mais jamais je ne me
gare sur sur les passages piétons et
tout ça jamais ces incidivité là moi je
rêve d'une voiture autonome je veux la
voiture
il y a une dizaine d'années et vous m'en
aviez parlé votre rêve à l'époque
c'était il y a du nouveau la législation
a changé ça ça me passionne et ils sont
au niveau 3 maintenant c'est à dire que
maintenant le seul véhicule autonome qui
a été homologué en Europe pour l'instant
c'est pas la Tesla c'est la Mercedes
quand même oui et mais j'ai pas encore
essayé ça va pas tarder et ça ça me
branche bien j'aurais pas peur du tout
mais vraiment pas peur
si on revient tout petit peu sur la
musique pour qui vous auriez aimé
composé par exemple
je trouve qu'il chante bien
c'est vrai que je suis mal placé parce
que je suis pas très musique française
moi j'écoute pas trop Angel j'aime bien
bah oui bah j'écoute pas trop non
vous invitez la Star Ac non mais c'est
pas grave hein
je m'en occupe cette semaine avec Cyril
parce que vous êtes énorme ça oui Benoît
non moi j'ai une petite question pour
vous Gilbert je voudrais savoir si comme
Patrick Hernandez vous aviez un titre
qui vous fait rapporter énormément
d'argent avec lequel vous pouvez vivre
toute votre vie sans sans rechanter
sincèrement c'est 100 euros par jour
encore lui le Patrick oui parce que il a
si ça a été une pub dans beaucoup de
pays et tout ça
je me pose pas ce genre de questions
dans le sens où moi je vis ma vie pour
chaque jour ce qu'elle est grâce à Dieu
je peux manger je peux voir de l'eau et
même un petit truc scotch dans le temps
Gilbert Gilbert j'ai dit quand on vous
écoute quand même parce que là il y a un
moment attention
Gilbert je suis prêt quand on vous
écoute là l'argent c'est pas important
un verre d'eau oui vous verrez vous êtes
heureux que vous souriez tout le temps
tout va bien vous avez bien les défauts
quand même vous vous énervez vous avez
c'est quoi vos défauts non c'est pas des
défauts c'est que des fois
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai pas fait d'album récemment j'ai
plein de choses que j'ai composé que
j'aime beaucoup mais j'ai peur du j'ai
peur de souffrir dans le sens où c'est
terrible quand tu fais un album et que
le public t'adore et que les médias ne
répondent pas à cet album Anthony mais
de quoi tu te plaintes façon tu as tes
standards qu'est-ce que tu veux de plus
alors en ce moment faut que je sorte de
ce de ce truc là je crois quand même que
je vais faire un album bientôt
et ma dernière question Gilbert vous les
paroles c'est souvent des auteurs
barbeliviens tout ça la musique c'est
vous parfois les deux c'est vous c'est
oui j'ai fait un titre qui a bien tourné
quand même et à 2 ans qui s'appelle la
nénéa et j'ai fait le texte bien sûr
j'ai fait le texte et musique souvent et
vous connaissez bien Johnny les pardon
c'est moi qui vous connaissez bien
Johnny Hallyday m'a-t-on dit ah ben là
c'est une affaire de cœur c'est
incroyable il me manque énormément pour
moi ça va être toujours été le meilleur
interprète en France moi je vous ai vu
dans N'oubliez pas les paroles rechanter
L'hymne à l'amour pardon c'était
exceptionnel j'avais les larmes aux yeux
vous avez gagné 100000 €, c'était
exceptionnel en vrai comme ça c'était
pas prévu et ben c'était ça veut dire je
savais pas le titre qu'elle allait
sortir alors là aussi j'ai dû un petit
peu batailler parce que il m'avait dit
bah oui mais alors comment on va faire
parce que les textes tu vas pas pouvoir
les avoir l'écran mais j'aurais dit il y
a pas de problème tu me dis pas tu me
les donnes pas mais tu les imprimes
avant et puis quand c'est le moment tu
me donnes la feuille que c'est le
problème c'est magnifique vous étiez en
bras et comme ça et de devant la caméra
et vous chantiez et c'est Mathieu c'est
un moment magnifique il est sur Youtube
le Braille est la seule écriture
sensuelle au monde
donc en tout cas juste pour vous dire
effectivement qui a une belle promo
aussi vous n'êtes pas venu que pour nous
voir même si c'est un plaisir Gilbert
Montagné ça s'appelle Luna ciel alors
parlez-moi
[Applaudissements]
alors
faut que je vous dise que ça ça m'a un
très heureux c'est un projet que j'avais
depuis longtemps de faire naître une
héroïne décrire une histoire d'une
petite fille qui qui est tout dans le
monde de l'image elle est la première à
l'école dessin et peinture et tout ça et
puis ils vont voir le village Père Noël
enfin land elle découvre les aurores
boréales elle s'éclate avec son frère et
ses parents et sur le chemin du retour
vers l'aéroport il y a un accident de
voiture elle n'est pas blessée personne
n'est blessée mais sa tête heurte la
paroi de du véhicule et elle a un
traumatisme crânien qui est engendre une
cécité d'accord alors au début
évidemment pour elle c'est j'ai pas
voulu tu vois je suis pas que caramel
mot j'ai pas voulu l'idée le fait que
elle flippe au début je dis comment je
vais faire ça y est mon monde est défini
et tout ça mais finalement elle va
découvrir une autre force et ça je vous
dis pas par quel par quel parc bien mais
elle va découvrir une autre force une
autre façon de voir parce qu'il y a
plusieurs façons de voir et c'est ce que
je dis souvent à des gens à qui je parle
à qui ça vient d'arriver genre des looks
je comprends très bien que tu flippes
pour l'instant mais mais la personne que
tu es sera la personne que tu es c'est
pas parce qu'on t'a enlevé l'énergie des
yeux l'énergie n'a pas été au thé tu
peux la recycler dans ton cerveau et en
faire autre chose et vous écoutez des
heures l'essentiel est invisible pour le
cœur le petit prince et vous avez écrit
un titre effectivement en plus pour pour
ce livre oui la même chose
[Musique]
j'aimerais remercier énormément
[Applaudissements]